well first of all I want to say hello
and welcome for those of you who don't
know me my name is Anna and I am the
president of our student chapter of the
Federalist Society here at Hillsdale we
are so excited to have you all with us
here tonight
and we were especially honored to have
mr. Leonard Leo speaking to us tonight
about judicial power and virtue so
before we get any further into the
program would you please stand for the
Pledge of Allegiance I pledge allegiance
it is my great privilege to introduce to
you tonight mr. Leonard Leo mr. Leo is
the executive vice president of the
Federalist Society an organization of
around 65,000 individuals
advancing limited constitutional
government most recently he has advised
President Trump on judicial Selection
helped to manage the Gorsuch selection
and confirmation process and has served
as a member of the transition team he
organized the outside coalition efforts
in support of the Roberts and Alito US
Supreme Court confirmations and in 2004
was the bush-cheney presidential
campaigns Catholic strategist Leo was
appointed by President George W Bush to
three terms on the u.s. Commission on
International Religious Freedom he was
also a u.s. delegate to the UN Council
and UN Commission on human rights during
the Bush administration Leo was a
recipient of the 2009 Bradley prize
along with the other founders and
directors of the Federal Society for his
work in advancing freedom and the rule
of law he is the co-editor of
presidential leadership rating the best
and worst in the White House as well as
the author of opinion editorials in the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
in the Washington Post Leo holds degrees
from Cornell University and Cornell Law
School he presently resides in Northern
Virginia where he and his wife Sally
have raised their six children would you
please join me in welcoming mr. Leonard
leo
well thank you very much and it's a
tremendous privilege to have been
invited back to the college to speak I
was here a number of years ago on
Constitution Day to deliver a lecture
and I remember well the experiences I
had here on campus with this wonderful
student body and I thank you for giving
me the opportunity to come back it's
actually a slightly different experience
because back then we didn't have a
Federalist Society at Hillsdale College
and we didn't have a Federalist Society
actually at any undergraduate
institution we have two now and that's
by choice and this is one of those two
the other is rice and so it's it's just
especially a privilege for me to be to
be here and visit with all of you it's a
great chapter and you guys are doing
wonderful work as many of you know it's
a time of real tension in in the world
of higher education but it's heartening
that I can say today what one could have
said at any time during hills dales
existence this institution is committed
to academic freedom intellectual
diversity and unbridled truth-seeking
and inquiry and of course the Western
and cultural tradition and all its
beauty and majesty
I hope you agree that this is the
highest compliment that can be given to
a university faculty administration and
student body and I mean it's very
sincerely my topic today is the judicial
power and virtue what exactly does it
mean to exercise the judicial power
virtuously the application of truth
fairness and equality certainly have
something to do with it but what I want
to do tonight is to get to an even more
fundamental or elemental understanding
judicial virtue should at it's very core
be about the faithful application of the
principles and rules the founding
fathers created to preserve the Worth
and dignity of every human person
and first amongst these rules and
principles that preserve human Worth and
dignity in this great country of ours
are the structural limits on
governmental power enshrined in our
Constitution the structural Constitution
if you will
judges have a profound duty to respect
and afford and force this structural
Constitution these core limits on
government power in virtue is not
possible in the exercise of judicial
power without this first it was Justice
Scalia who often warned that without the
structural protections that restrain
government power guaranteed rights don't
really have much to back them up what
gives force to those rights is not the
lofty ring of the words it is the
clearly defined limits on the reach of
government enumerated powers
decentralized authority separate
branches checks and balances the
federalism to sovereignty of the people
these are the elements of structure and
ultimately they are met what make the
Bill of Rights more than just a wish
list
I traveled far and wide as chairman of
the u.s. Commission on International
Religious Freedom you can go to some
pretty grim places and here boasts about
all the rights they recognized all the
UN declarations they've signed and on
and on and on look a little further
though and you'll find ranked and often
cruel persecution outside of small house
churches in Indonesia State Security
Officers photograph worshippers who are
then targeted for discrimination
Buddhist monks in Vietnam and China are
swept up from the streets and detained
visit a coffeehouse in Pakistan or
Nigeria were Egypt and there's a decent
chance you'll encounter a Christian or a
minority Muslim with a story of being
beaten by a mob for his beliefs while
police stood by and did nothing to help
if such treatment is not directly the
doing of governments in those countries
it is the doing of private actors
routinely tolerated by those governments
and high sounding declarations of rights
parchment barriers are no defense
Justice Scalia figured this out long ago
before I did and taught me this basic
fact
as he only would put it every tinhorn
dictator in the world today every
president for life has a bill of rights
that's not what makes us free what has
made us free is our Constitution think
of the word Constitution
it means structure so if the mission is
truly to protect freedom anywhere then
you are in the business of restraining
the powers of government and happily we
in the United States are still a world
away from those other places where
freedoms are ringing Lee declared and
rarely honored Hillsdale students may
find this proposition relatively obvious
but not so amongst much of the left
which has had a chokehold on our legal
contra culture for many years for
generations when it has suited their
purposes some progressives have held in
effect that the Constitution means
whatever five or more members of the
court say it means in practice this is
given what I this has given us what I
see is to transcend jurisprudence
neither of which bears resemblance to
how the framers viewed the structural
Constitution or our third unelected
branch of government we see the first
trend in the creation of rights found
nowhere in the tucks text or structure
of a constitution often risking a
virtuous and democratic society whose
elected representatives should be
allowed to shape our culture to note
some examples almost at random Griswold
versus Connecticut brought us the right
of privacy so general and vague that its
application is purely subjective that in
turn led to roe v-- wade and a long line
of cases affirming a right to abortion
with ever narrowing exceptions for
reasonable restrictions and regulations
in similar fashion obergefell versus
Hodges announced to write the same-sex
marriage
Miller versus California limited the
authority of states to restrain the
production and distribution of obscene
material Everson versus Board of
Education and many follow-on decisions
created a sort of right to protection
from religious influence in the public
square
consistent constitutional reasoning is
not what ties these various landmark
opinions together on the contrary it's
their excess of nuance
the common features are vagueness
malleability and self-aware pretenses to
legal rigor almost invariably we're
invited to join the majority opinion in
some labor journey of the mind
striking delicate balances applying
multi prong tests discerning ever
evolving standards though it's always
cast in the independent in the in the
language of independent truth seeking
somehow we always end up in the same
place an overreaching Court a court were
any majority of five exercising will
instead of judgment can decide
essentially whatever they please
now if the goal were to avoid the whole
messy business of free and open debate
among the people and our elected
representatives this would certainly be
the way to do it the only problem is
such an exercise of power by nine
mortals given lifetime tenure is in my
view unjust and deeply dangerously
undemocratic that's one trend in
jurisprudence the second tenth is a
tendency to overlook what is plainly
evident in the Constitution when you're
finding things that aren't there it's no
surprise when you miss things that are
there
this is most pronounced in areas where
the court is called upon to enforce the
structural Constitution the separation
of powers limited enumerated
responsibilities under article 1 section
8 of the Constitution and federalism
failure to enforce these structural
limits has brought us a nearly unlimited
administrative state to which Congress
has wrongly granted a mix of legislative
and judicial as well as executive powers
this specifically listed legislative
powers are so broadly construed that
exclusive enumeration becomes almost
meaningless permissive constructions of
the power to spend or to provide for the
general welfare or to regulate
interstate Congress commerce rather have
all kinds of practical consequences they
allow Congress to venture into areas
that were intended to be left to the
States or else free of government into
altogether when the court doesn't
enforce even the most obvious
constitutional provision the abuses of
power quickly add up in this way Grutter
versus Bollinger brought us race-based
quotas that violate equal protection
under the law the campaign finance cases
Buckley vs. Valeo and McConnell versus
FEC permit Congress to effectively
restrict core political speech without
the most compelling justification kilo
versus city of New London essentially
did away with the public use requirement
when government employs one of its
bluntest powers of all the taking of
private property we speak often of the
activist court inserting itself where it
doesn't belong in these cases the
problem is the passive court absent
where it does belong too often missing
from the picture is what the framers
envisioned the dutiful court exercising
only its rightful and essential powers
and making certain that the other
branches do the same moreover a truly
dutiful court can only exist once its
members exercise judicial virtue rather
than mere judicial overreach of course
judicial overreach is a complicated
problem and there's no short of a
shortage of excuses for it many writers
on the subject lay blame on Congress for
passing laws so vague as to leave judges
no choice but to act and think as
legislators Justice Scalia raised this
point in one of his dissenting opinions
he observed fuzzy leave the details to
be sorted out by the courts legislation
is attractive to the congressman who
wants credit for addressing a national
problem but does not have the time or
perhaps the votes to grapple with the
nitty-gritty other see judicial
overreach as an unavoidable result of
the welfare and regulatory state they
cite decisions of the Warren inne burger
courts which continually defined
constitutional standards for new federal
programs in education and housing and
other areas it has become common to see
Law Review articles that examine court
decisions
from this angle weighing social economic
and political factors and often
discarding traditional legal analysis
altogether Chief Justice Earl Warren is
said to have asked himself in
scrutinizing a law is it right is it
fair rather than simply is it
constitutional in some quarters this is
considered standard practice and
entirely praiseworthy political
scientists offer a third explanation for
our state of judicial overreach they
point to shifts in the electoral cycle
and national politics for example during
transitional periods when power changes
hands and the elected branches the
Supreme Court tends to act in a counter
majoritarian way in each of these
attempts to account for the growth of
judicial power
doubtless there's a bit of truth but
surely the problem lends itself to a
simple simpler causal explanation it's
the one I suspect Lord Acton would
settle on and all the framers to as
usual with abuses of power the reason is
a desire for power and that could not be
further from faithful application of the
framers structural Constitution long
stretches of the Federalist Papers are
meditations on just that subject lest
anyone forget how mindful the authors of
our Constitution were about power and
its temptations let me turn the floor
over for a moment to James Madison this
quote is from the Federalist number 51
and many of you are probably familiar
with it if men were angels no government
would be necessary if angels were to
govern men neither external nor internal
controls on government would be
necessary in framing a government which
is to be administered by men over men
the great difficulty lies in this you
must first enable the government to
control the governed and in the next
place oblige it to control itself we see
this commentary play out and how the
framers envisioned and devised judicial
power judicial review ensures that the
structural limits on government
authority will be
policed and enforced by the courts at
the same time though the framers
expected the judiciary to exercise very
limited powers leaving the heavy lifting
of policy development to the political
branches the best explanation here again
worth quoting comes from Alexander
Hamilton in the Federalist number 78 the
judiciary has no influence over either
the sword or the purse no direction
either of the strength or of the wealth
of the society and can take no act of
resolution whatever it may truly be said
to have neither force nor will but
merely judgment a worldly man like all
his peers in Philadelphia Hamilton
surely knew that abuses of judicial
power would occur but I'm quite certain
of this he could never have imagined
where we are today the real trouble
began when judicial abuses came dressed
up as constitutional doctrine a prime
suspect in all of this is the legal
realist school of the early 20th century
it gave us a sociological conception of
law concerned mostly with the social
effects of law and courts rather than on
the proper allocation of government
power realism meant viewing the law as a
means to an end
a tool in the expert hands of social
engineers and who better to do the
engineering than a judge who can set
policy by decree the short of it is this
unless the starting premise is that law
has a determinate meaning the outcome
will always be unpredictable and only
coincidentally related to the designs of
the Constitution you can give such legal
theories any impressive sounding name
you want but here's the reality the only
name that's really going to matter is
the name of the judge who decides the
case and benevolent motivation is no
safeguard against pure whim eventually
it becomes a matter in the best instance
of well-intentioned policymaking and in
the worst instance of
what justice Byron right white memorable
memorably termed acts of raw judicial
power
the real EO legal realism school only
grew more shorts sure of itself over the
years and it fell to serious thinkers
like Antonin Scalia and Robert Bork to
start puncturing the balloon we can
thank them for setting legal thinking in
our time back on the firm ground of
originalism and textualism by sheer
force of argument they and others like
them became a commanding presence in the
debate from there was a short step to
originalist judges on the federal bench
appointed by President Reagan and by
both presidents Bush not every nominee
made it through all the way and some of
us remember the treatment of Judge Bork
as most ruthless but some exemplary just
justices have joined the court and
better still and at the present moment
we can be hopeful that others will
follow the short of the matter is that
to exercise judicial power virtuously is
to appreciate that the most essential
work has already been done for us by as
astute and wise a collection of men as
ever assembled some juris this day's
like to hold forth about changing times
and all the various features of modern
life that the framers couldn't possibly
have foreseen what they miss is the
timeless insight reflected in that
document above all the understanding of
history and human nature that is at the
core of constitutional structure that
allocates and limits government
authority since there are very few
constraints on the judicial power that
can be invoked easily and regularly more
often than not the exercise of virtue on
the part of a judge will be a matter of
volition rather than force or some set
of temporal incentives and that makes
the assessment of character very
important in the business of judicial
selection I have witnessed the
importance of understanding and
practicing judicial virtue most directly
and palpably in the judicial
confirmation
most recently the battle over the
Gorsuch nomination was largely a clash
of visions about the role of government
and the scope of its power the left
opposed his nomination in good part
because his judicial philosophy
evidenced a skepticism about a boundless
administrative state in light of our
system of the separation of powers
Gorsuch saw a role for the court in
policing those powers and one can trace
concern about lawless administrative
discretion going all the way back to any
number of provisions in Magna Carta and
a structural Constitution here at home
carries the theme forward our newest
justice Neil Gorsuch is among a good
many legal jurists who stress the
importance of the structural
Constitution that will be a welcomed
influence on the court in keeping with
the wisdom of his predecessor here's how
the president put it in the swearing-in
of justice Gorsuch over the past two
months the American people have gotten
to know respect and truly admire our
newest member of the United States
Supreme Court injustice Gorsuch they see
a man of great and unquestioned
integrity they see a man of unmatched
qualifications and most of all and most
importantly they see a man who is deeply
faithful to the Constitution of the
United States he will decide cases based
not on his personal preferences but
based on a fair and objective reading of
the law that is a concise Job
Description that covers a lot of ground
meet all the standards those words imply
and you will fill every role in every
circumstance when you think about it
after all there's nothing terribly
complicated about the virtues alluded to
here needed by every great judge to hold
firmly to the application of the core
principles of our constitutional order
because they perfectly match the
cardinal virtues prudence the first
virtue st. Thomas describes st. Thomas
Aquinas describes this as wisdom
concerning human
fairs and also as having right reason
with respect to action we need two types
of knowledge when surveying any
situation knowledge of the moral
principles guiding human nature and an
understanding of the circumstances at
hand it's the combination that gives us
sound judgment then there's justice at
its core this embodies the constant and
permanent determination to give his or
her rightful due it's the virtue that
blinds us to anything and everything
except equality before the law and
there's temperance the strength of
character to stand above the seductions
of power status and acclaim
no one ever given a robe and gavel is
unfamiliar with those temptations and
when a justice of the court gives in to
them it's not a very inspiring sight and
then the fourth virtue fortitude the
courage to stand firm and our
convictions and our duty against all
pressure and adversity if a justice of
the Supreme Court cannot be counted on
to show complete fidelity to the
Constitution and laws of the United
States then how can we expect that
anyone can in government one final note
about these virtues they define the
ideal and therefore no one is ever going
to be the perfect exemplar of any of
them on the other hand we Americans
above all know how close to the mark an
inspired collection of people once came
but for them we would not today have one
of the greatest works of human wisdom
the Constitution of the United States it
has never been and never will be too
much to ask the judges in our country
exercise their power virtuously through
honorable adherence to the structural
Constitution and in so doing to bolster
the Worth and dignity of every human
person presently serving jurists have
enduring examples to follow in justices
whose reputations still command respect
and always will faithfulness is always
at a premium and never more than today
in the current search for men and women
who will take up and live up to that
obligation the good news is that an eel
Gorsuch and a number of lower court
judicial appointments for the past year
we already have found a number of them
and the great news is that many more are
on the way thank you all very much happy
to take questions
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming my question
is with the death of Antonin Scalia do
you foresee as we continue on into the
future do you foresee jurisprudence
getting better or do you feel like the
idea of textualism is going to die with
Scalia well there a couple of
observations I would make about that
first I think at the end of the day the
future of textualism and original
original ISM it is really going to
depend on on future presidents and
sentence in other words you know I think
it was Reagan who once said you know
personnel is policy and ultimately we
have a number of members of the court
presently who are textualist a fewer
number who are originalist but still a
number who are originalist but that but
that balance can change that balance can
change with with new presidents who
don't ascribe to that judicial
philosophy don't have people around them
who ascribe to that judicial philosophy
and it can certainly change with
Senate's that treat the court as a
political body and are not interested in
in the blind administration of justice
but rather look at results in cases so
that's that's a challenge I think that
at least the early returns on justice
Gorsuch or that he does in fact ascribe
to textualism and originalism he said as
much in his confirmation hearings
certainly his body of work before his
nomination evidenced that there have
been several
a couple of opinions where he has
discussed originalist principles and
several oral arguments where he has
asked very probing questions relating to
the original meaning of the Constitution
I think all of that is very positive and
I think pretty consistent with with what
Justice Scalia's views of jurisprudence
were but again you know we have a court
where I think at least at least two of
the justices are over 81 and there is
going to be a lot of changes in the
composition of that bench over the next
decade or so and we should not take for
granted the Renaissance we've seen in
originalism and textualism it can be
taken away from us just as quickly and
easily as it was regained very enjoyable
and and insightful it seems that you
called it a Renaissance and is it true
than that one of the key elements in
this Renaissance has to be law school
teaching and is that something that
you've seen shift in the direction of
originalism and textualism or our law
law students receiving their education
in that through the Federalist Society
through reading Scalia and Bork reading
you listening to you are they receiving
it outside of law school or have you
seen a shift in teaching and instruction
at law schools there's been a shift in
law school teaching there is a greater
degree of discussion in the classroom
itself about originalism and textualism
and about the structural Constitution
but make no mistake the reason why there
is that shift it's because of the
external forces that have come to bear
upon the law school Academy
there would be little need for
professors to to talk about those things
in the absence of wonderful Scalia
opinions and effect and the sense there
would be no reason for Law School
professors to tip their hat to a
conversation about originalism in the
absence of a federalist society that was
having a meeting on it at 4:00 p.m. that
same day so I think some of what's
happened here is law professors want to
control some of this conversation they
don't want to cede the entire discussion
to these external forces and so they let
it into their classroom and so I think
there has been some change now if you
want to see a more lasting change if you
want to see I think a greater foundation
laid for these rule of law principles
that's a project that extends well
beyond the law school that starts well
it starts here it starts at colleges
like Hillsdale who placed a premium on
our Constitution and on the bedrock
principles of our republic it it falls
upon high schools to have a proper
understanding of what civics education
really means how about take out the
Constitution and read that you know for
civics education so so you know we need
all of that
we need we need to shift and we need to
preserve that Renaissance in the law
schools right because because that's
where the opinion leaders for the law
come from but as I've just mentioned
there's a political component to this
and and that means that you need to have
a broader citizenry or body politic
that's invested and bought into the game
and and that's where this broader
educational Enterprise needs to really
take root
Supreme Court justices earlier do these
at all promote judicial virtue or would
the removal of life tenure and all
improve judicial virtue in the court
system I've never been of the view that
getting rid of the life tenure would
have much of an impact on judicial
virtue now why do I say that well first
of all if you look at state Supreme
Court's around the country where there
are often limited terms or elective
terms that doesn't seem to affect their
behavior and so I'm I'm not I'm not
convinced that limiting terms will
affect behavior
I guess one can make the argument that
if you limit terms you could you could
get rid of really bad people sooner but
the fact of the matter is that if you
have a political process that isn't
appointing the right people in the first
place that doesn't do you a whole lot of
good either
so my operating principle has generally
been the most important thing you can do
to create a pro rule of law pro
regionalists pro textualist Pro
structural Constitution atmosphere is
basically to have political officials
who care about that stuff and you know
we just went through a presidential
election which you know for the first
time in my memory was really all about
that right you know a week after the
election I was summoned up to New York
to sit down with the president-elect and
talk about what the Supreme Court
process was going to be like and you
know winnow lists down and all of that
good stuff and and the first thing he
said in the meeting was you know this
this you know this issue really had
consequence and he rattled off the
numbers he knew the numbers
22
23% of the American people who voted
said that the Supreme Court was was the
most important issue in this election
and it was 60% of Republicans those
those numbers are historic highs so this
was the first time at least in my memory
that issues of judicial power right and
the role of the court and and what was
at stake with the court was actually
squarely presented to the American
people and many of them reacted in a way
that historically they hadn't certainly
having an empty chair at the court
brought the issue home for people but
you know that issue was brought home for
people also because we had a
presidential candidate who made it a big
issue talked about it everywhere he went
put out a list of you know 21 names to
say to everybody this is this is the
list from which I'm going to pick these
are the kinds of people I want this is
what principles those people reflect
that was a big deal so brought it to a
head in a way that we had never seen
before
thank you so much for coming tonight sir
you mentioned the unpredictability of
decisions as one of the problems with
the legal realist school and insofar as
some of the precedents you mentioned
have already been decided how should a
court that wishes to restore some
integrity to the structural barriers in
the Constitution approach precedents
that in the past have allowed the
government to step beyond its bounds
while at the same time getting due
respect to sort of constant seeing legal
decisions well you'll get okay it's a
tough question right because you
actually get a variety of different
perspectives about this within the
conservative movement actually so you
know in fact some of you may be familiar
with with a bit of the tension it was
friendly but a bit of a tension that
existed between justices Thomas and
Scalia on this subject Justice Thomas
was what often jokingly called himself a
faint-hearted originalist right because
he had a little more a little more
willingness to accept a long-standing
precedent that you know that that that
expectation interests had been built
around and and where there was at least
some kind of a discernible judicial
standard right and justice Thomas was
has from time to time been more of the
view of now if the president's wrong
would just overturn it and so there's
there's a bit of a spectrum within the
conservative movement about what role
precedent ought to play I I tend to be
on the side of thinking that precedent
that that cannot be justified by the
original meaning or by textualism is
ultra vires and basically ought to be
set aside it it harkens back to
something that Bentham said do I
normally don't like to quote but I think
he said that which precedent is that
which someone invokes which is untrue in
other words you know it or something
words of that effect and and so
I think there's something to be said for
that I mean basically if it's if it's
wrong then it needs there's a very
strong argument that it should be
eliminated I would say that there are
there are variations in in the courts
jurisprudence on this you know for
example I think that certainly a Supreme
Court decision that has no discernible
judicial standard does not deserve to be
treated with the respect that the stare
decisis would normally accorded so for
example I don't know what the undue
burden standard is in abortion
jurisprudence I have no idea what that
is and and and so that's a precedent
which I think should get zero weight
there are other precedents in the
Commerce Clause area where there are
judicial standards we can have a debate
about whether that's the right way to
read the clause the interstate commerce
power or not but their standards they're
discernible they're uniform they create
expectation interests and and you can
make an argument that in that instance
if you're gonna start wiping press it in
a way you know you probably need to do
it in a more measured fashion if at all
so I know that's sort of an ambiguous
answer I tend to fall on more of the
Thomas side of the spectrum but I think
there's a fair debate in the movement
about the proper role of stare decisis
thanks so much for your time tonight sir
I really appreciate it my question for
you is concerning the relationship
between federal law and state
enforcement of those laws and I wanted
to ask you how you feel about the
growing discrepancy and/or divide
between the federal law concerning
immigration in state enforcement of
those laws and how do you see that
adapting and evolving over the rest of
the term
presidency well that's a good question
because I mean that current debate which
is often described in you know political
or policy terms is really is is really a
really cuts to the core of our
constitutional system in a lot of ways
right I mean I I think our framers
envisioned a system where basically
there were certain very discreet
enumerated powers and Congress has
authority to regulate those areas and
states have a duty to respect
congressional authority in those in
those areas and they can't make
decisions for themselves they can't
decide to refuse to respect or enforce a
federal mandate in an area where
Congress has plenary authority or
specifically delegated authority and
obviously in areas like immigration
right where where you're dealing with
questions of naturalization and
citizenship and national security and
control of our borders those are federal
questions and and states and localities
have a duty to respect federal
prerogative in in those areas and so to
answer your question in a very practical
way
I think Jeff Sessions Attorney General
Jeff Sessions got it right right sue the
state of California and and you know you
do that because you know there's an
assertion of congressional authority
federal authority that needs to be
respected states need to be really
careful about this right because the the
allocation of national and state powers
is very delicate and I think once states
start ignoring those balance of powers
right it may it may cut in their
political favor one day but will very
much cut against them another day
you know this is reminiscent of that
that one of those closing scenes from a
man for all seasons where you know st.
Thomas more does a Roper I think talk
about cutting down all the trees and
what's left right you know you as a
state you want to be very careful about
eliminating these these structural
protections even though there might be
some short-term political gain by doing
it in this case ignoring the federal
government's mandates with respect to
immigration so I think that's the first
question always has to be what's the
congressional authority under article 1
section 8 is it there if it is states
have to basically respect it this left
to be the last question of the evening
thank you for your talk I was struck by
the word virtue in your talk and I know
virtue is taking a beating is that
required when you go to Hillsdale I
thought I had a yes you know virtue
signa good virtue this virtue that it's
it's taking a bit of a beating I was
also struck by your point about the need
for a citizenry the set of a certain
character and so I'm wondering you know
what in your judgment are some of the
best most practical most effective ways
to actually foster virtue in a citizenry
you know such two citizens understand it
love it and practice it
well for me first and foremost would be
faith and family I think an
understanding of virtue or of the good
as you would put it here can be realized
most readily read it readily through a
deep spiritual life through a
development of a friendship a true
friendship with God and so I think that
first and foremost is extremely
important couldn't say that at too many
colleges but you can say that here
secondly his family right we've you know
the concept of subsidiarity has been
with with mankind for a long long time
and there is something practically
useful about it right I mean you know we
know it works and so you you you you
want to try to inculcate values at the
most decentralized core level that you
can and you have intact families are
really really important for the
development of of a virtuous citizenry
and every major political commentator
and writer has has recognized that and
then you just sort of gradually work
your way up to the local community and
so forth but family and faith are really
the two most most important things and
it's no coincidence that in the Western
cultural tradition right as family and
faith waxed or waned
so did so did a more virtuous citizenry
and more virtuous leadership I'll end on
this note because I think this is a good
question to end on that's the great
thing about your project here you know
many of you probably did come from
intact families who cared about your
education and your rearing and many of
you obviously
have a faith of some kind or another
belief in God make an effort to develop
a deep spiritual life a friendship or
relationship with God what's great about
this institution is that it takes all of
those things that those those
foundational blocks that were laid in
the earlier parts of your life and it
allows that to flourish and build upon
it and so you're getting a great
education here for four years please you
know use it for good when you leave fine
I mean you know you'll have your jobs
and that may be to advance the free
market or to to serve people in in some
particular profession or another but
you're also all citizens and you also
all going to have duties to maybe maybe
raise may raise children who will
respect the principles you're learning
about here maybe maybe that's not your
calling maybe the calling is is is to
work within a community of other people
and inculcate these values when you get
out of here but you're deeply and you're
deeply involved in this project and the
education you've had is a tremendous
privilege because it gives you unique
ability to help to advance our country's
principles into the future so I'm very
grateful for
Hillsdale being here and especially
grateful that there are people like you
who want to populate this institution
and hopefully go out and and apply all
the principles and virtues that you've
learned about here so thank you very
much it's a pleasure for me to be here